joining us now to break down all of this
South Carolina Senator Lindsey Graham
there's a lot to decipher here can I ask
a question on this first memo I would
like to know why this I assume this came
from the FBI
I assume this director ray saw this this
letter to the Foreign Intelligence
Surveillance Court this is July of 2018
Lindsey they're justifying the use of
the dossier when it was a year and a
half earlier that they debunked the
dossier well you nailed the first part
there's two things really important
tonight the Legal Foundation for
Muller's employment is crumbling the the
memo to Muller from Rosenstein was given
to me today or yesterday by bar fully
unredacted virtually unredacted so now
we know that the scope of the
investigation was to look at Carter page
Flynn Papadopoulos and manna fort as to
whether or not they were working with
the Russians now this is an August of
2017 you've nailed it in July of 2009
you arey 2017 the sub source disavowed
the dossier and without the dossier
there's no warrant so they knew that the
the Carter page thing was a fraud
January the 4th 2017 the FBI field
office wanted to close the case against
Flynn we've got Papadopoulos on record
denying working with the Russians saying
to do so would be treason so the
foundation for the Muller investigation
is crumbling now in slow downloads I
want to I want to stay on the timeline
here this is this is important you're
right that's why I'm going through this
scope memo this is August of 2017 rod
Rosenstein Senate now we're up to the
fourth FISA application the third rule
now
let's stay on the dates for one second
the only source for this had to be steel
by August of 2017 for the scope memo and
the final
new allure the 4/3 renewal the 4th
warrant by that time they knew back in
February of 2017 that it was Russian
disinformation and there was only one
source and the source was steel they
knew it was BS months earlier so now the
question senator is what the hell went
on here well the legal foundation to
justify Muller's appointment in my view
does not exist that's what this memo is
so important they named four people
Rosen Stein tells Muller to look at four
people August the second 2017
Carter pages one of the four you've just
said it better than anybody January 8
months before the sub source disavowed
the dossier there was no legal
justification to suspect Carter page of
being a Russian agent because it all
depended on the dossier and that
crumbled in January Flynn's case was
looked at by the field office in
Washington January the fourth of 2017
they said there's no reason to believe
he is doing anything wrong he shouldn't
be part of crossfire hurricane
Papadopoulos his own tape in 2016
denying working with the Russians to say
to do so would be treason so there was
no legitimate reason to believe any of
these four were working with the
Russians on August the 2nd 2017
therefore the entire Moeller
investigation was illegitimate to begin
with that's very important it's not only
illegitimate senator we're talking about
a shredding of every bit of
constitutional law due process that we
would ever have and they're doing it
from the very beginning
never verifiable to stop somebody from
winning election and when they win the
election they are trying everything they
can to use false information to
basically take this guy down and they
knew what they were doing they had all
the evidence that they were doing it and
they did it anyway so lest
slow down for a second I wish it
Democrat would take this seriously I'm
not sure Muller hold your breath you'll
drop dead you're right but but I
supported the Muller investigation
because I didn't know now I know now I
know why Muller didn't find anything
they knew their to find Lindsay there
was nothing there just proves they knew
Danny knew before it even started they
knew ok parameter to the FBI and the
Department of Justice is writing to the
FISA Court in 2018 now this is 2018 in
2018 January of 2018
Devin Nunez writes a memo critical of
the FISA application Grassley Graham
memo is very critical of the Carter page
warned application here's what the court
is told by the FBI and the Department of
Justice in July 2018 they say in the
letter to the court no the application
is good as solid as sound a few
technical irregularities and they repeat
the lie that the sub source was truthful
and cooperative in other words they're
telling the court that the sub source
validated the dossier rather than
shredded it they're actually repeating
that lie again in 2018 only until
Horowitz came along do we know why
couldn't they found what Horowitz found
in the file you have a memo right there
for anybody to see indicating that the
sub source the Russian sub source said
the dossier was a bunch of garbage it
was hearsay Bartok senator all of these
people broke the law didn't they I'm
telling you man this is this is Jagger
Hoover stuff we're gonna have hearings
and and Barr has been terrific I've got
I've got it I agree with you on Barr I
don't think any of this comes out for
bill bar filled well on its own where's
director ray though I've got a lot of
people yelling at me tonight he's not
doing his job well in in July 2018 how
could you possibly tell the court that
the sub source was truthful and
cooperative when the memo when the file
says he undercut the dossier they're
repeating the light of the court that
Horowitz found that tells me the FBI has
not taken
seriously the abuse is associated with
crossfire hurricane as late as July 2018
that's what it tells me beyond any doubt
cetera this was an attempted coup this
was shredding to Constitution we're
getting to the bottom of it